يحييكم من جديد خلال المقابله التي اجراها
لكن مع العربيه كشف ان ايران رفضت العرض
الذي كان على الطاوله فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق
النووي مؤكدا تصميم اداره بيضين على ضمان
عدم امتلاك ايران لسلاح النووي حيث شدد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه على ان الاتفاق
النووي لم يعد اولويه بعد رفض ايران
العروضه بالعوده اليه مؤكدا في الوقت نفسه
ان الحاله دبلوماسيه هو الاكثر فعاليه
بهذا الملف ولكن خيارات اخرى في حاله فشل
الجهود الديبلوماسيه بحسب الوزير الامريكي
لينك قال ان التركيز الان يتجه نحو
الاحداث العديده التي تحصل في ايران
والقمع الذي يمارسه النظام الايراني بحق
شعبه مشيرا الى ان النساء الايرانيات
للمطالبه بحقوقهم ويشدد لينك على دعم
واشنطن وعدد من الدول للشعب الايراني الذي
يحاول كما قال اسمها صوتي والمطالبه
بحقوقه وفيما يخص تغير وتغيرا نظام
الايراني قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان
الشعب الايرانيه وحده بامكانه اسقاط
النظام او تغييره اما فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقات بين طهران وموسكو قال بلنكن ان
ايران تدعم روسيا في حربها ضد اوكرانيا
وتقدم لها المسيارات والاسلحه الاخرى
نحو الاحداث العديده مثل قمع المظاهرات في
ايران النساء يدافعنا عن حقوقهم ويتم
قمحهن بعنف من قبل النظام وفي نفس الوقت
نرى ايران تدعم روسيا في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا وتقدم لها المسيرات والاسلحه
الاخرى ونرى ايضا ان الدبلوماسيه هي الحل
الوحيد لبرنامج ايران النوويه الرئيس كان
واضح ان كل الحلول مطروحه لمنع ايران من
الحصول على اسلحه النوويه
[موسيقى]
الشهاده
الايراني
وقال بان كانت ايران فرصه في الواقعه ولم
تقتنصها لم تقبل باقتراحات المجتمع الدولي
ورفضت هذه الفرصه هل نفهم بان هذه الفرصه
الاخيره وبانا المجتمع الدولي واشنطن تفكر
في حلول في حلول اخرى
لا اعتقد بالطبع ان الفرصه التي يتحدث
عنها بعد جولات المفاوضات في فيينا وبعد
اخذ والعطاء في اكثر من ملف ااه كانت
ربما محاوله اخيره قبل تصعيد العقوبات
وقبل السير بسياسات اخرى لكن حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا وازمه الطاقه والمواقف
الاوروبيه التي تبحث عن اعاده تدوير بعض
الزوايا والتواصل بشكل غير مباشر مع طهران
تبقي حدا ما من الدبلوماسيه حيا يضاف او
يذهب بموازات التصعيد ان في العقوبات او
في بعض العمليات التي تجري داخل الاراضي
الايرانيه او حتى في تصعيد الكلام الذي
نشهده لكن بلا شك ان ما يجري داخل ايران
الان واا الانتفاضه النسويه والشعبيه في
ايران تبطئ ايضا محاولات الاوروبيين البحث
عن مخارج او اعاده دعوه طهران الى مفاوضات
فقط اشير الى ان اا فرنسا والمانيا
وبريطانيا وتحديدا فرنسا التي كانت تقول
انها الطرف الوحيد القادر على مد جسور مع
الايرانيين في ظل اصطدام الامريكي
الايراني باتت الان من كافئه قليلا عن هذا
الملف وتتابع شان المعتقلين الايرانيين
الفرنسيين والايرانيين اصحاب الجنسيه
المزدوجه
وبالتالي هي ايضا في مرحله تصعيد لكن
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدبلوماسيته لم تقطع
تماما مع طهران ولو ان الظروف لا اعتقد
انها مشجعه لاستعاده اي تفاوض في المرحله
الثانيه
وهنا كذلك مسار نحن نعلم بتفاصله وهو مسار
العقوبات ولكن قال بانه في حال نفذت كل
الحلول فان لدينا خيارات اخرى النظام
الايراني كيف يلتقط مثل هكذا تصريحات
طبعا الخيارات الاخرى تتكرر دائما
ودائما الخيارات الاخرى يقال بانه لو لم
تصل الجهود الدبلوماسيه الى نتائج هنا
خيارات اخرى على الطاوله هذا هذا القالب
الدبلوماسي نسمعه يتكرر دائما خاصه مع
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه
نفس هذا القالب الذي لم تعد تصدق
انا باعتدي لو كانت الاداره الامريكيه جده
همم اتخذت منذ فتره طويله موقفها ولكن
المساله التي جعلت الاوروبيين يصحون من
النوم
ويسقطون على الولا المتحده الامريكيه او
يقفون معها في جبهه واحده مساله مجيء
الصواريخ الايرانيه ومسيرات ايرانيه الى
البيت الخلفي الى ال- ال- الحديقه الخلفيه
لاوروبا عندما كانت الدول الاقليميه تصر
على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ونحن نعرف
هذا الاصرار ادى حتى الى تعكير العلاقات
بين دول الاقليميه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لهذا السبب الان شعره بما كانت
الدول الاقليميه تتحدث عنه ومساله الانشطه
الصاروخيه الايرانيه وانضافت الى الانشطه
الصاروخيه الانشطه المسيراتيه الايرانيه
كل هذه الامور لم تهتم بها اوروبا الا ان
وجدوها في اوكرانيا اي وجدوها خلف ابوابهم
لذا اعتقد المساله تتغير تتغير نتيجه
ثانيه
الامور صارت اقرب ربما خليني اسال دكتور
في هذا الاطار دكتور زياد هل همم مسيرات
ايران الموجوده او التي تستخدم في الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه قد توجع اوروبا قد
توجع واشنطن وقد تلزمهم باتخاذ همم ربما
قرارات همم يعني خليني اقول اكثر قسوه من
التي كانت تتخفف العقوبات يعني
هو يعني يصعب الان قراءه الملف الايراني
الغربي من دون البحث في تعقيداته ومن
ضمنها الجبهه الجديده التي تنخرط فيها
ايران بشكل غير مباشر في روسيا واوكرانيا
لكن كان هناك ميل عند كثر في اوروبا للبحث
عن تناقضات يمكن ان تنويج بين طهران ومسكو
اولا لان الاهداف مختلفه ان في مقص التمدد
الايراني الاقليمي والسطوه الاقليميه او
حتى في مقاس محاولات ايران الابقاء من
جهتها على تواصل مع الاوروبيين يتيح لها
المناوره ويتيح لها بدورها التمييز بين
اوروبا وامريكا الموضوع الان بسبب تعدد
الجبهات بسبب مساله الطاقه بسبب همم
المحاوله ربح الوقت همم الايرانيه وهي
سياسه معوده في الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه
البحث دائما عن بعض المكاسب وربح الوقت
وانتظار ما قد يكون افضل من دون اي ت كل
ما اقول تنازل طبعا بين مزدوجين همم هذه
الامور الان باتت بسبب تحدي الحرب في
اوكرانيا بالنسبه للاوروبيين ليست اولويه
الرهان على ان تبيع ايران الطاقه لاوروبا
ايضا ليس يعني رهانا دقيقه بسبب العقوبات
وبسبب عدم الاستعداد الايراني لتقديم بعض
التنازلات وهناك الملف الداخلي الايراني
الذي يعرقل كل هذه الامور لكن فقط ملاحظه
لو سمحت لي يعني في ما تعلق بوشنطن
السياسه الامريكيه وقت باراك اوباما كانت
تقول باولويه الوصول الى حال نووي نبحث من
بعده بباقي الامور حصل ذلك وباقي الامور
لم يتحسن فيها شيء سياسه ترامب كانت سياسه
من دون افق ايضا لان الخط الذي جرى يعني
نوع من الخط العشواء همم من دون ااه وجود
وضوح في الرؤيا ومقاربه للمنطقه همم الان
مع الاداره الحاليه هناك لا لا اريد ان
اقول ارباك لكن مجموعه ملفات في نفس الوقت
الصين وروسيا هي قبل ايران وقد يكون لمزيد
من العقوبات اثره ايرانيا ولا اعتقد ان
واشنطن ستذهب ابعد من ذلك في المرحله
المقبله
قادمه يمكن ان تتخذها واشنطن البعض كذلك
وضع فرضيه التحرك العسكري ولو ان العالم
همم لا همم يؤيد مثل هكذا خطوه لانها كذا
خطوه ستفتح النار على الجميع ولكن هل يمكن
ان تضع واشنطن هكذا همم حل قائم لو اراد
ذلك بامكان هذا تتخذ هذه الخطوه هي واشنط
ليش عاجزه في اتخاذ هذه الخطوه عندما
اتكلم عن واشنطن لا اتحدث عن بيت الابيض
فقط انا اتكلم عن امريكا بقوه بامكانها ان
تنتخب هذه الخطوات ولكن الاشاره الا
الحاليه لا اعتقد بان الاداره الحاليه ااا
جزء من همم استراتيجياتها في التعاطي مع
الملف الايراني مبني على مساله توجيه
ضربات عسكريه هي لا تزال تحاول ان تستفيد
من اخر الاوراق الدبلوماسيه الممكنه حتى
تتمكن من جعل ايران تتراجع وتقبل بالشروط
الايراني وشكر كذلك الحظر تكون باريس
دكتور استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه
باريس مشاهدينا دائما للنقاش بقيه غدا في
نفس التوقيت معه مواضيع اخرى السلام عليكم